quelques jours je vous emmener avec moi
à san francisco pour ni à tout est à
l'envers je me décale moment et la
coucou c'est moi qui vous parle pour
venir découvrir les nouveaux samsung
galaxy s 20s 20s vente plus elle sera
ultra est aussi le nouveau smartphone
pliable le z flip le z flip qui a une
nouvelle proposition de valeur qui au
lieu de se payer pour agrandir la
surface va se plier pour réduire la
surface un peu comme le faisaient les
smartphones à clapet avant et justement
aujourd'hui j'ai une excellente nouvelle
a beau se cacher nos mondes l'appart
lougatois hélas le z flip vient
d'arriver
alors je suis super content parce que
vous savez quand il ya des nouvelles
innovations est toujours content d'en
parler bien souvent le monde du
smartphone nous propose des choses un
peu semblable il ya assez peu de réelles
innovations
you may mais pas tout le temps pas tous
les jours et quand il y en a je suis
très heureux et justement aujourd'hui on
va se faire un petit tour on va 5 boxer
et flip alors pourquoi vous pourrez me
demander pourquoi monsieur gros tu vas
un boxer un smartphone que tu nous as
déjà présenté le jour tout simplement
parce que l'autre jour c'était une
première prise en main lors l'événement
ce qui est aussi génial c'est de voir de
quelle manière la marque en l'occurrence
ici samsung va travailler packaging est
ce qu'ils vont proposer une autre forme
d'un boxing pour nous emmener employeur
pour nous raconter notre histoire
ou alors est-ce qu'ils vont rester sur
ce qu'ils font sur ce qu'ils savent
faire sans prendre trop de risques et
c'est vraiment ce qui m'intéresse avec
certaines banques sigalens justement
j'ai voulu attendre pour ouvrir et voir
tout ça avec vous le faire devant la
caméra est vraiment vous partagez mon
ressenti à cet instant là vous invite
donc dès maintenant faire deux choses la
toute première serre vous abonner si ce
n'est pas déjà le cas pour tout savoir
sur l'actuelle nous amène avec moi dans
mes voyages on parle des 6 quelques
jours à new york il va y avoir plein de
voyage cette année qu'est le deuxième
point demandé de me laisser un joli
poussent vers le haut un joli chèque
mais vous savez l'algorithme de youtube
est comme ça et pour faire progresser
les vidéos pour faire progresser les
chaînes il faut les laïcs et il faut les
aimer envoyez-moi de l'amour envoyez-moi
du lac et marquera tout ce que vous
voulez en bas en commentaire à léonie
20%
il me faut des ciseaux un carton des
ciseaux un carton
[Musique]
ah ouais ça nous somme vraiment joué la
sobriété là dessus regardez moi ces noix
sur moi c'est assez marrant d'avoir fait
ça comme ça il a rien qui absorbe
particulier on le voit bien marquer sur
le côté si samsung galaxy z flip rasé il
n'y a pas de fioritures c'est vraiment
une toute petite boîte
on va vraiment le z là qui se détache
mais rien d'exceptionnel
y'a rien de bien neuf il ya rien qui
vous sautent aux yeux attendait ça sauf
comment comme un petit tiroir comme ça
deuxième niveau de lecture flip
on va vraiment à quel produit en
affaires au dos toujours rien toujours
très simple et sobre
on ouvre petite information ça me saoule
bloqué là je viens je tire dan quê
instruction là le smartphone voyez quand
on voit comme ça on a l'impression que
c'est n'importe quel smartphone qui est
grand ouvert et on sera pas qu'on peut
devenir le plier comme ça alors attendu
comment ça souffle ce truc
si j'ai une languette la danse à saoula
de côté en eau
d'accord il ya donc 2 cette fois ci
normal il est partagé en deux ans on
pourrait dire c'est plutôt logique
on prend on enlève on a le petit numéro
de série derrière dont on se fout
royalement
et voilà c'est vrai quand on voit comme
ça on a l'impression que c'est n'importe
quel smartphone à smartphone standard
garder je vous le mets à côté d'un
iphone c'est un smartphone stand à un
poil plus long et encore mais la réalité
et c'est là où la magie ce cash et ça
c'est génial
alors on a ça on a ça ah ça c'est
marrant ça arcade et il nous met un
petit message ce futur hit shape meet
you galaxy z fleet bouliac mon accent
français
c'est juste magnifique effectivement
d'un petit bruit sur le fait qu'il est
révolutionnaire ensuite à l'intérieur on
a quoi on a un bloc de charge du
standard il n'est pas fou c'est un
boxing parce qu'il n'y a pas grand chose
de dingue
j'aurais espéré qu'ils ne vont pas
vraiment quelque chose de différent de
différencions aller plus loin samsung
serait vraiment eu un sens et pour le
coup c'est pas ça c'est un peu dommage
usb usb c'est vrai qu'on pouvait
s'attendre à autre chose surtout un
produit qui coûte quand même
relativement cher des petits écouteurs à
cacher qu'on va avoir filaire avec les
petits enfants qui se branche
directement ici en usb c'est qu'est ce
qu'on a ici on doit revoir
rassurez vous ça ne souffle pas le
smartphone que ce soit comme ça de quoi
vraiment tiroirs de karting ici à un
petit coup de skybox couic couic stamm
guide chaud comment transférer ces
informations entre ces différents
smartphones ok ça marche
une petite coque de protection ça nous
montre comment venir un style c'est
quand même pas mal qui veut dire avoir
une coque de protection ont alors fait
de voir le truc ça c'est quoi ça c'est
les bandes bandes adhésives peut-être
donc ça ça vient en bas ici ouais ok là
c'est en attaque qu'on vient enlever ici
vient se positionner
ça vient juste en renfort en secret
petit le mans d'ici bon écoutez
franchement c'est pas trop les parce que
je m'attendais à ce que ça casse un peu
le design mais n'ont pas trop c'est pas
parfait mais une fois de plus on est sur
un smartphone qu'il faut venir protéger
ce qui est bien c'est quand il se plie
voyait et bien l'écran intérieur est
complètement planqué là ici vous risquez
pas de devenir l'abîmé en le frottant
parce que vous avez la coque donc ça
c'est pas mal c'est assez discret ça
casse pas le design on a quand même
quelques avertissements qui nous sont
données par samsung ne pas toucher
l'écran où l'objectif de la caméra de
celle ci avec un objet dur cela pourrait
les endommager
lorsque le smartphone est ouvert ne pas
m'être d'objets de cartes de crédit de
pièces de clés sur l'écran ou ont évité
de le rayer quand même ce smartphone
n'est pas résistant à l'eau et à la
poussière ne pas l'exposer au liquide
aux petites particules ne pas m'être
d'adhésifs ou de stickers sur l'écran
principal
est-ce que ça je vous l'avais dit
effectivement d'un écran vert mais par
dessus c'est un film en plastique
je pense que le film en plastique risque
de s'abîmer ce n'est pas que ça fasse
comme le problème du galaxy fold au
début alors au début vous savez les gens
venaient tirer un peu et enlever la
protection plastique pensant qu
effectivement c'était juste une
protection d'écran alors comment c'était
l'écran lui-même koussa endommagé et il
était mort là par contre on a un écran
plastique au dessus d'une dalle en verre
donc là dans leur merde protège mais par
contre le film plastique sivom et un
sticker sur ce que vous tirez vous
risquez devenir le décoller il à vous
allez endommager votre écran et de la
même manière votre écran plastique qui
risque de rayer si vous mettez un studio
que ce soit ça risque de marquer
extrêmement facilement donc n'y allait
pas avec des ongles alesi vraiment avec
votre doigt c'est bien mais c'est un peu
le problème aujourd'hui cette techno les
limites en tout cas de cette techno lors
après je me demande si au niveau de la
fabrication si on n'a pas une partie des
verts uniquement sur la partie du haut
et sur la partie du bas et c'est la
partie centrale ici c'est pas uniquement
du plastique ça me paraît très normal je
vois comment publier du verre de vue
purement physique vers vers film en
plastique qui vient le lier en plus il
bon je veux un peu regretté que tout ce
qu'on trouve ici c'est pas complètement
ouf au niveau donne donc si j'aurais
préféré avoir une expérience un peu plus
d'1 go mais apparemment écrit flip noir
sur noir avec cet effet là il n'y a pas
de grande surprise
j'adore cette proposition de valeur qui
fait par samsung là dessus car des mois
la taille du truc comme ça c'est
vachement grand c'est très long et
lorsque vous le plier ces minuscules
vous le glisse est extrêmement
facilement dans une poche c'est tout
petit si vous comparez avec la taille de
mon iphone ça n'a strictement rien à
voir c'est quand même plus épais c'est
quasiment le double mais c'est pas
extrêmement déformant il ya de la place
dans la poche ça bouge ça me dérange pas
trop entre l'iphone qui dépasse ça c'est
le 11 pro mac sont quand même très très
très grand jeu mais lui pour le coup
j'ai de la place alors on va s'allumer
ce truc
samsung galaxy z flip salut toi
j'adore ce format je trouve vraiment
cool loyers pourrait mettre comme ça
vous venez le bcsa je vous l'avais déjà
montré dans la vidéo de présentation
mais voyez l'intérêt c'est qu'on peut
venir lequel est comme on veut il ne
bouge pas alors le maître comme ça ça
n'a strictement aucun intérêt mais le
maître comme ça le poser sur une table
et notamment pour venir faire des photos
là ça devient extrêmement cool
lorsque je me mets en mode photo jeu
mais comme ça là l'appareil photo vient
occuper toute cette grande surface
et lorsque je le pli il remonte pourront
plus utiliser comme ça comme un petit
poudrier élan plus il ya un petit truc
sais pas si vous avez bien vu là je
voulais activé il est au nord je peux le
mettre hors peu le métro ça en fait
c'est le petit retour moniteur vous
allez avoir sur le devant et je trouve
ça quand même relativement rigolo donc
vous voyez on est comme ça
tac j'ai fait une photo de l'autre côté
est en réalité ça vous donne une photo
comme ça voyons voit pas grand chose
devant une espèce de petit rectangle
comme ça c'est rigolo mais ça sert en
fait à rien parce que qu'on peut pas
s'en rendre compte réellement de ce
qu'on vient chute est là dessus à côté
de ça les usages sont quand même
nombreux on pourra venir faire du
multitâche or tout ça on le verra lors
du test vous avez donc dès maintenant à
vous abonner il à côté qui est résistant
qui robuste et qui est surtout
extrêmement rassurant on sent que le
truc est une vraie résistance au niveau
de la charnière on sent pas un truc qui
y voyaient qui bouge qui fait n'importe
quoi alors si je veux retrouver
complètement bout d'un mois avec un
parent bouger ça me paraît normal
j'aime beaucoup l'histoire ça raconte
l'idée du format un peu déçu par le
boxing pas ce que j'espérais qu'on ait
une boîte un peu différentes communes
proposent en valeur + sexy
ça nous raconte un peu autre chose quand
on arrive dans des produits d'exception
dans les produits qui sont très atypique
comme ça je m'attendais l'expérience
aussi un petit peu atypique j'avais
davantage trouvé au niveau du galaxy
fold d'ailleurs je vous invite à y voir
mon âme boxing si vous ne l'avez pas vu
mais sur le galaxy z
liszt voilà je serai plus on a faim mais
vous voyez lorsque on va mettre 1500
euros dans un smartphone c'est pas
problématique mais j'aurais aimé une
meilleure expérience au niveau de
l'aisne boxing une boîte un peu plus
cool un peu différente
l'argentin petit peu dans les boîtes
qu'on connaît du côté de chez samsung au
niveau des galaxy s
au niveau des galaxy note mais j'aurais
bien les mettre un petit peu plus
transcendé ça raconte une autre histoire
[Musique]
théo quand tu trouves vas-y ouvre
quasiment sa pas casser ça te plaît
ouais tu pourras avoir un produit comme
ça oui bah ça c'est bien parce que tu
vois dans les sacs à main sont nickels
c'est une question de sa caméra
directement quelle logique que tu vois
ça abîme pas l'écran alors ça fait un
peu retour dans le passé quoi tu trouves
sur la forme ouais c'est vrai dans ta
poche témoin dans une poche taupin ça
dépasse un peu cdt price a cédé mini
poche oui c'est bien merci
[Musique]
voilà donc pour ce premier déballage
deuxième prise en main du galaxy z flip
la dernière fois c'était aux us donc le
première prise en main en europe je peux
le faire comme sa première prise en main
en france dans quelques jours je me
dirais réellement ce que j'en pense
donnerait vraiment mon retour à usage
sont de la photo sur la vidéo sur du
multitâche sur un côté un peu pratique
pas pratique
est-ce que l'écran de notification est
intéressant aussi avoir quelques
informations le soir est ce que c'est
bien de venir l'ouvrir le refermer
est-ce que c'est ennuyeux est ce qu'au
contraire c'est extrêmement pratique
je vais tout vous dire d'ici quelques
jours dont vous invite dès maintenant à
vous abonner s'est pas déjà le cas
et bien évidemment laissez-moi des
jolies pouces algorithmes faisant que
volume de l'amour l'amour c'est vous
regardez moi je vous envoie plein
d'amour plein coeur n'hésitez pas à me
poser toutes vos questions suggestions
interrogations tout ce que vous voulez
en bas en commentaire quant à nous on se
retrouve dès demain pour continuer à
parler tech - vous avez l'amour
regardez j'adore puis il fait plus comme
je vous l'avais dit deux fois que
j'étais à san francisco up all mètres
devant sauf un petit micro devant la
bouche
la ration alimentaire nous embrasse à
deux matchs
mais
[Musique]
j'ai vendu des abonnés